so real quick i would just love to to
introduce uh dr venueraz uh she just had
a simple
uh introduction because of the time uh
she is a training and outreach
coordinator with hereditary health and
uh what's the third age you're gonna get
to know
bowel network south africa so uh
uh dr vinomiraz are you there
yes i'm here
okay please uh can we give her the the
uh co-host right so that she can share
our screen
she's already
all right uh please just go into into
the full screen mode so that we can see
your screen maximally
can you just confirm that you are seeing
my screen and not the presenter view
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we can see you
now
great okay perfect so hi everyone
yeah
yeah
okay sure let me just see if i can
switch
it is kind of in the presenter mode we
can still make use of this yeah perfect
now
sure okay so you can see it now yeah
perfect so hi everyone i am very nervous
um i
packaged so i just want to thank
everybody for firstly inviting me um to
be with you all today
it's it's
been a really wonderful day so far
actually i've really been enjoying all
the presentations all the talks and from
and learning from everybody else's
experience as well so i'm getting a
warning that my internet is a little bit
unstable so if you all don't mind i'm
actually going to just switch off my
videos so that my screen stays up and
you can hear my audio
but i'll switch it on a little bit later
if my internet stabilizes a little bit
right so just to give you an overview of
what i will be just touching on briefly
with this talk i would like to give you
all a brief overview of hca buying it
and who we are
um i'd like to cover very briefly as
well some of the hda bionic training
and also our training models
i will discuss our multiple delivery
training model in a little bit more
depth than some of the other things i'll
talk about because this is a model that
we really really are really proud of um
as as an organization and a lot of
development went into this model and and
i'll talk to why it's been such an
amazing model for us and then i'll also
talk to how we've adapted this model
more recently for much more advanced
bioinformatics training and then i'll
touch on some of the other mechanisms
that we are using to share our training
and make it a little bit more reusable a
little bit more findable
and interoperable so i'll speak to fair
and bio schemas a little bit and then
i'll speak to the dsi africa initiative
but more specifically um el wazi which
is the open data science platform and
the
group that i'll be forming part of going
forward
so for those of you who might not be um
too familiar with us i just thought i'd
do a quick introduction to hr buying it
so h3a bionic is a pan-african
bioinformatics network and we are part
of the human hereditary and health in
africa consortium also known as h3
africa
and at the moment we are currently
comprised of 28 partners and we are
spread across 17 different countries and
so we have quite a nice representation
across africa already which i'm quite
happy about and i'm sure everybody's
quite proud of
and we have over 200 members at the
moment so we are quite a large
consortium at the moment
but h.a bionet was established to
develop bioinformatics capacity in
africa and more specifically to enable
genomics data analysis by hd africa
researchers across the continent and
that was our our initial goal and aim
that it's expanded a lot more since then
but mainly basically h.a bionet is
developing human capacity through
training and support for data analysis
and also facilitating access to
informatics infrastructure by developing
or providing access to pipelines and
tools for predominantly human microbiome
and pathogen genomic data analysis
and so the major goal of course of hr
buying it overall is then to increase
the number of qualified bioinformatics
graduates on the continent but also to
create research opportunities and also
very importantly provide some financial
support for promising new graduates in
the area of bioinformatics
one thing h.a bionic really wanted to do
was to kind of slow the brain drain in
africa and attract some africans back to
the continent um who are studying abroad
so to make africa more attractive as a
bioinformatics you know
leader across the world
and so one of the ways that we of course
do that is through training and that's
um predominantly what i do as part of
h.a binet i work with training work
package and we work on um you know
designing inclusive training models um
and
just unique training modalities so that
we can reach as many people across
africa as possible
and so h.a bionic does training in a
number of different ways um so we have
run over the course of the last decade
or so a lot of face-to-face workshops
we've done a lot of train the train at
style courses so we focused on
developing capacity in trainers
we've also
awarded quite a few internships
and so internships have obviously slowed
down a little bit during the cove years
now but um before that we did try to
move graduates around so they could get
hands on who experience um in different
labs and that's also been something that
we try to push quite a lot
we've done a lot of live and online
training
and we also focus a lot on hackathons
and jamborees and each of these
components are done with a different end
goal in mind
and i want to say that when hga bionic
just started
um obviously the focus was a lot on
face-to-face workshops
and so
with that we ran many face-to-face
workshops but we realized very very
quickly we've got a huge network across
africa and when we run face-to-face
workshops we are reaching 20 to 30
people per course per workshop and so
that was really just not good enough and
so
we wanted to create models that could
reach more and more people across africa
simultaneously so that we could actually
train more people simultaneously and in
that way also increase capacity for a
lot of this type of work
and so one thing we really worked very
hard on is developing this sort of
multiple delivery mode training model
and so it uses a lot of different
approaches um to to teach particular
courses the first course that we ran in
one of our flagship courses is our
introduction to bioinformatics course um
and this course was around because of
course there was a need for just
foundational training across africa when
h.a buying it just started up a lot of
people wanted foundational training but
we couldn't run you know 100
face-to-face workshops in a year
and so what we did was we decided well
let's try this multiple delivery mode
training model and it was designed to
reach multiple classrooms multiple sites
across africa at the same time and how
the model works is that we would
basically have institutions apply to
host the classroom so we'd have a call
for classrooms um they went through a
regular selection process and if we if
we felt that they had the
the capacity to run the workshop they
were accepted as a host we then allowed
a round of participant applications and
each classroom basically had this set of
participant applications they did their
selections as well and these
participants then joined that classroom
but what made this you this model really
really unique is that although it was a
distributed classroom model within each
classroom we had a coordinator we had a
teaching assistant and we had a systems
admin for on-site support and then we
had all of us in the background as the
core team
also supporting those classrooms with an
added level of support and so what this
allowed us to do is to reach hundreds of
participants across numerous classrooms
every year now we're running ibt
actually now for the seventh time this
year and last year we had something like
50 classrooms running at the same time
spread across about 15 or 16 countries
in africa
and we had close to 2 000 people taking
the course at the same time and that was
really fantastic for us
so the whole course we feel is quite
scalable we started with about 26
classrooms and it grew organically to
about 50 classrooms i don't know if
we're gonna have more than that this
year because my capacity is waiting a
little bit thin to manage everybody um
but yeah
for all intents and purposes as long as
you have more hands on the core team the
model can continue to grow on end really
um but what we did with this particular
model is we made use of a lot of online
tools initially because we wanted to
remove that infrastructural burden on
the classrooms because they were spread
across africa they all had different
issues at the time sometimes they they
were low resource in terms of capacity
some classrooms had intimate internet
and so we all are aware of a lot of the
problems in africa it's a very very
heterogeneous sort of environment and so
this kind of made the environment a lot
more homogeneous because now um
everybody was using the same online
tools and so all you really needed was a
computer and a browser and you were good
to go
but then we started training thousands
of people across africa and so now
everybody was coming back to us and
saying well this model is wonderful
but how can we do something more
advanced can we do something more
advanced
and so
at some point myself and a and another
training person at hsa buying it went
well let's try and do something more
advanced and see how it goes and that
kind of spurred and
sort of led to the development
of an adapted multiple delivery model
and so what we did with um 16 escorts
that we ran for a couple of years now
is we actually had
a bunch of people from different domains
come together so we had us as the
trainers and the curriculum developers
we had developers come together
sys admins come together and we decided
well let's try and package all the tools
the data sets software dependencies
packages everything into a container
let's actually now try and get these
classrooms to pull that container
install it manage it run it locally
and then see how they fare
and so what we did with this particular
model is we had a smaller cohort of
classrooms because now the
infrastructure became very important
h.a pioneer has invested a lot in
infrastructural development across all
of our nodes across africa and so we
were quite confident that the
computational resources were there
in most cases and so we also wanted to
have them develop their the their own
ability both for 16 years analysis but
also for
planning these kinds of courses and
workshops on their own even if they
share buying it disappears for whatever
reason so what we had them do was pull
these containers give all these students
access to their servers or clusters
wherever the container was hosted and
they actually needed to run analyses in
the cloud for the course
and so this
a lot of people kind of told us um
you're a little bit crazy we don't
really think this is going to work um
but i'm really proud to say that it has
worked and it's been working for a few
years now
um and we've run i think about three or
four iterations of the 16 years course
now and at the last course we had about
30 classrooms who all ran this course in
this sort of model and it worked really
really well
one thing we also do with the model is
we actively manage everybody with a
learning management site and so we
actually track every single participant
all the time and so we give them graded
tests and assignments
there's lots of feedback tools forums
and we manage literally every single
participant quite actively and we also
create everything that they do and so
this was a very exciting model for us to
see work um it also then
caught the interest of the international
community really and
last year for the first time we teamed
up with the welcome test and they've got
a wonderful ngs course that they run
but their course is run obviously with
with a slightly different model so they
use a vm
and so we tried this model last year for
the first time um for that njs course
the vm was incredibly large it was about
40 gigs unpacked when it was up it was
20 gigs and so each participant had to
pull this vm and then you know work with
us via the learning management site and
online lessons
because of covert they couldn't join
their physical classrooms anymore so the
whole course became virtual
but it still worked it became a truly
blended learning experience but it was
really exciting for us to see that
whereas the welcome class could reach 20
people per workshop and they ran the
workshop maybe twice a year
last year alone i think we reached i
think over 300 people with with that
training and it ran for about three
months this year we have about 600
people on the course and 59 classrooms
doing ngs and other season really
advanced analyses um so they're doing
everything from qc to rdc chipset genome
assembly
really the whole shebang they they're
going they're working their way through
the content and they're managing and so
that's also been really exciting for us
and so i won't speak to to a lot of
these these topics um
in too much detail um just in the
interest of time but i did want to just
touch on a couple of other things that
he buying it has been doing
um to just increase and grow the impact
across africa as well
and so one thing we are focusing on
quite heavily not just in training but
overall is the concept of fear so making
everything findable accessible
interoperable and reusable and so we are
making sure that we are really hitting
all of those fair indicators whether it
be with our software in tools or with
our training materials and um one of the
ways that we are making things more free
is also by implementing bio schemas and
so we are currently testing the
implementation of bioschemers um so
bioschemers allow you to mark up your
website with some semantic text and so
it allows obviously scrapers web
scrapers especially to find
um your content quite easily
at least in the case of training
materials and so there are three
different schemas that relate to
training and so we're trying to
implement them and what this will help
other web scrapers and people who host
catalogs of training for example to do
is to automatically pull in any training
we've ever done um once these keyboards
are implemented and again in that way we
are making our training materials
very much more findable and accessible
um and it's also being duplicated in a
lot of other repos which which i think
is very exciting
we also have embarked and assisted with
a lot of competency development for
bioinformatics
so the international society for
computational biology has suggested a
core set of
competencies that they would like
bioinformaticians to have
and so what we do is we actually use
those competencies to drive all of our
curriculum development even workshops
and courses are mapped to competencies
because it's very vital to us that we
actually develop these competencies at
an appropriate level for the for the
audience or the user the end user
so what the the iacb competencies have
done in the past um
is that they've come up with a whole
bunch of personas i've just taken a
snapshot of a couple of the personas
there are very many more than these
um and then what they've done is taken
the competencies they suggested core
competencies
and they've used bloom's taxonomy to map
out you know at what level does all of
these different personas need a
particular competency and so what that
does is really just help drive the
development of your course and make sure
that you're hitting the the competency
at the correct level for that particular
persona and so i've just got a couple up
here on this screen you can see i've got
a physician a lab technician a physicist
and a bike curator for example and then
i've just pulled out um just a snapshot
of some of the competencies these are
not all of the competencies they are
more than these um but these are just
the first few so you can see here that
um
basically we map we use bloom's taxonomy
to map the level or the depth of
knowledge that they would need or
ability or competency for these
competencies
so just for example
statistical research methods
we would basically suggest suggest that
all of them basically have knowledge to
comprehension level in terms of bloom's
taxonomy but a buyer curator might not
have to um
yeah so a bike creator would have to
have this competency at this level
whereas the others could have it at a
lower level but we use it in that way to
just kind of develop curricula and it's
been very interesting the way that our
curriculums have actually changed as a
result
and so
these competencies are actually being
further developed now there's a paper
coming out i think in maybe about a
month's time maybe less where we
basically are expanding these
competencies to include more data
science competencies but also adding
knowledge skills and attitudes and so
we hope that that will also assist
everybody in using the competencies and
there are there's a lot of other
developments happening around these
competencies um so lots of tools at the
iecb for example are working on
automated tools where you can code to
the website for example and say um i am
a physician and i want to learn x and
they will talk out what competencies you
actually need to develop to be
considered um
you know competent at a particular level
so that's been quite interesting for us
one other thing that that h a binary is
focusing on quite a lot are guides and
sops um so if you visit our website
possibly after this talk um you will see
that
we have
a lot of sops a lot of how-to guides
that we've been developing that's based
on a lot of our work i'm not going to
talk to obviously all the others but
i'll talk to the training guide
we've developed quite a comprehensive
training guide as well so if you do not
have experience in running
bioinformatics courses we've put
together
just a very short guide it's not very
comprehensive but a quick guide um to
guide you through the main steps that we
typically take when we design our
training and these steps are on the
slide so you can see that we think quite
thoroughly about the way that we do
training these are our steps just for
workshops um courses sometimes can can
be a little bit more complex and of
course degree programs a lot more
complex than this
but um this is our our basic training
workflow and so we follow this for each
and every course that we design and what
we've done is we've packaged that into a
little um just a simple pdf document
that also has a whole bunch of templates
and little help guides that can help you
do training in the way that we do it if
you're interested in that of course but
we've made lots of resources available
everything's been created under creative
commons licenses and so you're welcome
to take it adapt it reuse it as you see
fit and so that's also something that
we're really excited about and all of
these resources are loaded onto public
repositories excuse me
the one that we use quite a lot is ziva
hub
so ziva hub is the uct instance
of fixtures so it's a local instance of
fiction
and so we use this quite a lot
to upload our materials
and to make it more findable it attaches
the doi it versions the materials and so
it's really quite lovely in that way
and we actually upload all of our
training materials now um on to xero hub
and so if you went to ziva hub now and
you search for a binary you'd actually
see all our all the course materials
that we've managed to curate so far
available as archives that contain
um
workflows slides often videos data sets
so just whatever you would need to
actually be able to do that training
hopefully on your own so that's been
quite great
now in the interest of time i'm not
going to speak to the dsi africa
initiative in too much depth but i just
thought i would tell you a little bit
about the
the um dsi africa initiative it's quite
sad for me to say that h.a buying it is
actually soon coming to an end we are
ending our funding cycle um we've been
funded for
i think more than 10 years now so
it's time for something new i guess
and so we've been funded by this new
inner hdsi africa initiative
and basically
the whole idea behind this initiative is
that infrastructure and capacity
development
are big focus of course of boosting
health research on the continent
and so
the work will be facilitated through
five-year grants that have been awarded
by the nih
by the the common fund which is called
harnessing data science for health
discovery and innovation in africa
and they've awarded actually in the
region of 75 million dollars
to various research hubs that are that
are in various places and are focusing
on different things um so some research
hubs are obviously data intensive um so
focusing on the science but then they're
also training groups that are focusing
on increasing just capacity for for
analyses and um there are also things
like lc research groups so groups
exploring the ethical legal and social
implications and then there's the open
data science platform and coordination
center which is um the group that i'll
form a part of going forward
and really this group just wants to
facilitate the development of a trans
african network of data scientists
so just to tell you just briefly about
the odsp
the odsp will in essence develop a
flexible scalable open data science
platform for the dsi africa consortium
to find and access data select tools and
workflows run analyses uh but very
importantly on a choice of computing
environments all through easy-to-use
workspaces
and then administration and support of
the core resources and consortium will
be con
kind of coordinated by a coordinating
center
and so um
those of us at the central hca pioneer
team we a lot of us will be forming part
of that coordinating center going
forward
but together please can you just round
up quickly so that we're going to have
the next uh panel i think we just have
10 more minutes for the african section
please continue
sure i thought it had 30 minutes but no
problem um all right okay sure so let me
just actually wrap up things so this is
just a quick snapshot of what that
platform is going to look like we'll
have all these workspaces where you can
basically choose um how you want to run
what you want to run
and it's going to be federated so you
can either bring the data to the tools
or the tools to the data and so you're
very excited about this whole initiative
and where it might lead african science
and that'll stop me